all right what are somebody likes uh
ghouls
it's not a ghost it's not a goblin it's
not a goblin it's a ghoul it's a ghoul
there's a sense of Mischief to it
I got one lost trouble and a goblin is
gluttonous and there's nefarious and up
to zero good the ghoul is also up to no
good but has a sense of humor about it
yeah it mostly needs to be fun for him
yeah so he's gonna like switch your
socks around and you know it's silly he
might bite you yeah
you keep trying to catch him you squeeze
him too tight he's gonna bite your
finger a goblin you even spot the goblin
doing his thing and you're you're in
trouble right away you're gonna have to
run yeah yeah yeah Goblin could kill you
ghoulie could probably kick it across
the room
yeah yeah you know what I mean you know
what's funny
I feel like you're right none of this is
it makes sense you know what I mean
God's Gonna wreak it's gonna stink up
your apartment for days the goals are
relatively odorless
[Applause]
[Music]